samedi 2 ok avec son fils mathis une
rare pause pour bernard drainville dans
cette course à la direction
combatif et ambitieux bernard drainville
ne s'est jamais contenté de la deuxième
place en journalisme comme en politique
pas question d'admettre que la partie
est jouée d'avancé
le père de trois enfants entend se
battre jusqu'au bout
depuis des mois il fait campagne du
matin au soir
une campagne qu'il porte dans toutes les
régions du québec
samedi je m'arrête des common côte nord
havre saint pierre
il avait des centaines de kilomètres au
volant de sa mazda
cette partie de nous vous faites partie
du québec et on s'occupe de vous puis on
met sur vous partout il martèle le même
message régionaliste la raison pour
laquelle je trouve important de bien
vous voir la raison pour laquelle je
trouvais important de revenir sur
l'accotement c'est pour marquer un peu
la vision que j'ai du québec t moi je
pense que le québec est fort de ces
régions même si bernard drainville
rappelle souvent qu'il est issu d'un
milieu agricole modeste des origines
dont il est fier d origine qu'il
présente comme un outil qui lui permet
de mieux comprendre les réalités
régionales et un fils de cultivateur
alors les petits milieux qui se prennent
en main la pie qui sert les codes la vie
qui se battent pour leur survie
je connais ça vient d'un milieu comme
sont l'ex journaliste se présente comme
un homme proche des gens et il n'hésite
pas à lancer quelques pointes à son
principal adversaire pierre karl
péladeau qui fait campagne avec de gros
moyens
il faut vivre comme l'a vraiment si on
va être capable de représenter le monde
puisse connaître leur réalité un moment
donné il faut que tu aies commune comme
il l'admet la notoriété de l'homme
d'affaires éclipse ses adversaires
la principale différence en percale et
moi ce que j'ai été testés mais il pense
avoir assez de temps pour convaincre les
militants péquistes en jouant
subtilement c'est ce qu'on met tous nos
oeufs dans le panier de la nouveauté de
la notoriété ou est ce qu ont misé sur
une valeur sûre qui a donné des
résultats probants
kill the key qui a été fidèle au poste
depuis 2007 à micro fermé certains lui
reprochent cependant d'avoir été trop
bavard
pendant la crise qui a secoué le
leadership de pauline marois en 2011
si le parti québécois lors se rapproche
pas du monde la fiv est à pors alors on
passera pas au travers
bernard drainville admet avoir souvent
eu tendance à en mener large mais il dit
avoir changé j'ai appris à devenir un
bon joueur d'équipé alors qu'au début
quant à yves journalisme journalistes un
sport solidaire j'ai appris à jouer en
équipe
à preuve le dossier de la charte des
valeurs où il dit avoir accepté de
prendre des coups pour le bien de
l'équipe péquiste
malgré les critiques il a présenté une
nouvelle mouture plus modérée de sa
charte qui reste selon lui une nécessité
je reste convaincu que des gens qui vont
voter pour un autre candidat ou notre
candidate à cause de ça mais je reste
aussi convaincu qu en a beaucoup je
pense qu'ils vont voter qu'ils
pourraient voter pour moi à cause de ça
parce que ils y croient comme une
majorité de québécois y croient et ils
ont vu que j'étais capable de tenir
debout dans des dans une tempête
mais il refuse d'être étiqueté comme le
candidat de la charte et rappelle ses
autres réalisations
c'est les réformes démocratiques la
lutte contre la corruption que j'ai mené
la réforme du mode de financement des
partis bernard drainville continue à
croire en ses chances de gagner et jure
qu'il n'est pas question de se retirer
avant la fin moi je veux aller au bout
de cette course là et je vais vivre avec
le résultat heureux peut-être des
semences sinon mais avec le sentiment du
devoir accompli avec le sentiment d'être
allé au boutte
il